- [Dion] Many crypto enthusiasts rejoiced
when the Securities and Exchange
Commission gave companies
a green light to sell exchange
traded funds in the US
that directly hold Bitcoin.
In just a few days of trading,
it became pretty clear
who the big winners were.
I'm going to tell you
who's winning so far,
why they're winning,
and what this could mean
for the future of crypto investment.
Let's get into it.
BlackRock, which boast
more than $10 trillion
of assets under management,
was the big winner on the
first few days of trading.
BlackRock's iShares Bitcoin Trust ETF,
known by the ticker IBIT,
brought in almost $500 million
and had more than $1.6 billion
of trading volume in the first two days.
According to Bloomberg Data,
Fidelity's Bitcoin ETF had
about $400 million in inflows
and did about $1.1 billion in volume.
The fund from Kathy Woods'
ARC Investment Management
had around $111 million of inflows
and just under $450
million of trading volume.
Other funds brought in just a fraction
of BlackRock's haul.
ETFs from companies like
Valkyrie and WisdomTree
each saw around $11 million
of volume in their first
two days of trading,
as my colleague Jack Pitcher reported.
Analysts predict that the
firm that draws the most funds
early will have an advantage
to become the go-to Bitcoin ETF
for institutional investors.
Since there were nearly a
dozen ETFs made available
to the public the day
after the SEC's decision,
no company could get an
advantage by being first,
so asset managers almost
universally cut their fees.
BlackRock originally planned
a management fee of 0.3%
for its ETF, but after it was
revealed that other managers
were charging lower fees,
they cut their fee to 0.25%,
and they lowered it to
0.12% for the first year
or until the fund holds
more than $5 billion.
In addition to the lower
fee, BlackRock's IBIT holds
around $500 million worth of Bitcoin.
That's more Bitcoin
than any other spot ETF,
with the exception of the
Grayscale Bitcoin Trust ETF.
Investors favor funds
that hold more assets
because it makes it easier
to buy and sell the fund.
That's especially important
with assets like crypto
that can have big swings in price.
Grayscale's ETF actually
holds 50 times more Bitcoin
than BlackRock's and has
seen more than double
the trading volume, but over
the first two days of trading,
those flows were all negative
and investors pulled
almost $600 million out
according to Bloomberg's data.
One big factor, Grayscale's
ETF charges a fee
that's six times higher than BlackRock's
and most other spot Bitcoin ETFs.
The numbers so far suggest
that investors dislike fees
more than they like large asset holdings.
So what does this mean for the
future of crypto investing?
Having BlackRock as
the primary Bitcoin ETF
could make a big difference.
First, it could mean a
lot more Bitcoin buying.
ETF asset managers need to buy and hold
sufficient quantities
of the underlying asset,
so as more people buy their Bitcoin ETF,
BlackRock will buy more Bitcoin,
and with $10 trillion of
assets under management,
BlackRock has a lot of buying power.
BlackRock and others have
already started making a pitch
to more traditional investors
about why they should
get into crypto.
Bringing in traditional
institutional investors
who manage millions or
even billions of dollars
is a big part of why the fees are so low.
To be profitable with fees below 0.3%,
funds will need to
bring in a lot of money,
into the tens of billions of
dollars, says Eric Balchunas,
the Senior ETF analyst for
Bloomberg's research arm.
The most popular Bitcoin
ETF also stands to bring in
a new group of investors who
haven't had a lot of exposure
to traditional investing.
That could be very profitable
as those investors get older
and invest more money in the future.
Bitcoin ETFs could also
create a dividing line
between providers.
Vanguard, like BlackRock,
is known for its low cost
investment vehicles, but Vanguard has said
it won't offer access to the
Bitcoin ETF on its platform.
The big picture is that based
on the early days of trading,
BlackRock is looking
well positioned to win
a lot of benefits from the
newly approved Bitcoin ETF.
That could set them up to dominate Bitcoin
and new digital assets that
are approved by the SEC
for years to come.
(cheerful music)